hey welcome everybody
um this is the nabari tutorial so how to
uh deploy your own
um navari and we'll get into some some
of the details shortly my name is s
Guild I'm a software engineer at
quantite you might see a few of us
around
we have Peyton here helping Andrew
and Adam as well so
um yeah we'll jump into it right away
um if anybody hasn't logged in yet can
you maybe raise your hand and
come around and help
okay great
so if you don't mind navigating to so if
you have logged in and cloned the repo
like like I said you should be able to
access the zero zero overview notebook
and this is what that looks like
so show of hands who has logged in and
is on this uh first notebook
hypnotize everybody on this on this one
notebook
uh no you can just start the small small
server whatever whatever server you want
you can start um there's only two GPU
instances two GPU instances available so
it might not be enough for everybody
uh to open the terminal and there'll be
a link to
um to clone the repo
all right so we'll give it a few more
minutes but um if you haven't done so
already could you please navigate to
nabari.demo.dev sign in with key cloak
register uh at the bottom and once
you've logged in you can start a
terminal session and it'll give you a
link to a repo which we'll want you to
clone down
it should be uh nabari Dev slash nabari
demo
right
yeah your your email address doesn't
have to be a real email address you can
use whatever email address to make sure
just make sure you remember it so if you
need to log in in the future for the
future you can do so
give it another minute or two but if you
have if you have questions during the
talk uh or the tutorial feel free to
raise your hand and we'll try to answer
them for you if they're too complex or
too they'll take too long we'll maybe
save them for the end
um but if you have any technical issues
you should see a pink uh Post-It note on
your on your desk
I will want you to kind of put it up put
it like this on top of your monitor so
that we can come around and help those
people who are who are having some
technical problems so
okay
is there anybody who has not navigated
to the zero zero overview notebook yet
okay
I will I'll walk through what it looks
like for those who are wondering so
that you'll find in here
at the volume of hit register
I'm gonna do
this what you'll do for the first time
register make sure you remember that
I remember that make sure to remember
your email address and password
and once you're
um signed in you can start a server you
can pick a size
small or medium it's fine there's only
two GPU instances of two GPU instances
available so
everybody
this should take you a couple seconds to
load or mounting volumes and
um
and pulling images and whatnot so it
shouldn't take more than a couple
seconds
um
if it does take a little longer it's
because we're having to scale up on the
on the back end and we'll talk we'll get
into more details but
shouldn't take more than yeah 30 seconds
or so
and once you've been dropped into
Jupiter lab you will want to
open a terminal session
and
on the terminal session you'll see a
link to a repo which we'll want you to
clone so let's copy that and then do
good clone in your home directory
and you'll see it here
so maybe show up hands of people who
have not gotten this far yet
okay very good
um okay we'll I'll log out of I'll use
my
this one okay so
we're getting started right now um so
there are some notebooks we put together
for you to explore and for us to kind of
go over what navari is and uh some of
the core features and at the end we'll
talk about how to actually deploy your
own nabari instance
um so I'm gonna start off by saying what
nabari is so nabari is a an opinionated
Jupiter Hub distribution that has
um that's running on kubernetes and it
includes a whole bunch of features and
services that we've integrated
um we take it's been maybe a couple
years in the making where we've taken
all these uh core features and
integrated them and we've also have a
way of deploying it quickly
via by terraform so it should be a
two-step process to initialize the
configuration file and then one one more
step to actually deploy your cluster and
that deployment process is um it's all
managed by terraform like I said and it
will be the the thing that creates all
those Cloud resources that you need
um
let's see here um I'm going to uh
briefly before we um before we actually
get started on the actual tutorial I'm
going to do something a bit a bit
different which is I'm going to try
deploying another nabari instance from
the current uh instance that I'm running
on so this is obviously not something
you would do in on your computer but
this shows you it shows you the the
process by which you would actually
deploy a cluster so just for the
purposes of this tutorial I'll start it
start a deployment now and then we'll
come back to it at the end of the talk
and see if it's uh see if it's up and
running so just to verify that this is
not actually running right now foreign
I will change that name then
so this is the configuration file we'll
get into this in a second I just want to
show you what it looks like to the boy
so
have the command saved so I don't mess
it up
so this is one command it has some extra
flags that we'll get into later on but
for now I'm just going to start the
deployment process
and we'll see if it works so
we'll get back to this in a few minutes
there are some free housekeeping
um we already talked about how to log in
um
we'll have some opportunities for for
you to uh watch us demo some features
that may not be
um
accessible for for all the attendees but
you can still follow along and then
there'll be some sections for each of
you to experiment or play with the
platform itself so you'll see this kind
of uh your turn
um section and you'll know that you can
play around
uh we'll also like I said if you have
any questions during the talk or
tutorial please raise your hand and
we'll try to answer them if they're more
more complex and we have time for them
we might save them for the end
um and if you're running to technical
technical issues you can just use your
pink post node and put it on the top and
Peyton or Andrew or someone will come
around and assist you so
um that's that's it so
um
maybe one final call call out everyone
is logged in and everyone's on roll on
the same page okay very good if not then
please uh please raise your handle put
the pink sticker on your laptop
um here we'll get into a bit more of
what nabari is
um like I said before Navarre is in a
native open source and scalable
all-in-one data science platform that
allows your team to work efficiently and
collaborate collaboratively we have some
features that we like to show off that
makes it easy board a team of data
scientists to get their work done we
have a Graphic here from our booth that
shows some of the core features or core
reasons why you might want to use
um navari get off to approach it's
opinionated but it's still very flexible
so you can add other features and
services that you might want or change
the ones that are currently deployed
it's currently deployed with all these
all the features that we have integrated
are all open source so Key Club Das
Jupiter and so on they're all they're
all open source
um libraries
um and yeah we'll get into more of this
uh in a bit so
some of the core features and
Integrations I'd like to highlight uh
Peyton will be going over a condis door
and desk in a few minutes and we'll also
show show off we'll just like to share
dashboards but there are a whole bunch
of other features that we just will have
the time to go over but we've kind of
highlighted them here for you
feel free to explore on your own we will
be keeping this uh the server or this
deployment up and running over the
weekend so if you like experiment and do
so through the weekend and then we're
gonna
move our remove everybody on Sunday
evening
okay
um
any questions before we get started
okay great next I'm going to be moving
over to the interfaces that we have set
up so
there are a handful of interfaces that
that nabari comes with out of the box
and the reason we have the reason we
have this is that many people like to
work in different environments so if you
like working in notebooks some people
like working in um
like an editor or an IDE like vs code
and some people like just not have to
deal with the browser at all and they
like to do everything from their local
machine so we have a way to SSH into the
platform itself as well so get into
those in a second
okay so now maybe some the first part
for for people to get their hands dirty
um if you go over to the left hand side
over here you'll be able to see a file
tree I have some files in my home
directory that you may not have but
that's that's totally fine
if you go to the shared folder quickly
you will see a handful of other folders
within there these are groups that you
may be a part of so I'm I'm a part of
these four groups or I guess these three
groups the examples folder is a place
for us to have some shared examples that
we can play with later on
um if you'd like if you want to navigate
to the analyst folder you should see a
remedy pie I'm going to just show off
that I can run this one quickly
and me very good um I maybe at this
point you can try creating a folder
sorry a file in this this folder the
analyst folder and maybe adding your
name or some kind of unique identifier
so you know that it's yours but you
should be able to see that everyone else
in this room has access to that folder
as well so maybe just try creating a
folder you can do so by right clicking
here adding a new folder or new files
and saying this is mine
and this is a this is a nice feature for
people working in teams uh you can have
shared files that you uh
um work that you use with your
co-workers uh you have them all shared
in one in one location and this is also
controlled by a mission system that we
have integrated the identity and access
management platform known as heat cloak
and we'll get into that a bit later on
as well but suffice to say that there's
a there's Rich permissioning built into
the into the platform
so
that is how you would create and make
files in Jupiter
next we'll move over to
to the big plus button at the top or
from the file browser you can go and
click new launcher and then from there
you can scroll over to or if you can
find the vs code pop out and we'll click
on vs code
this is a feature that a lot of my
co-workers like to use uh they they
prefer perhaps working in vs code as
opposed to working in jupyter notebooks
for certain project for example and this
is a this is the code server vs code in
the browser application so
again you can go to the file file tree
and you can see your your files and your
what you're working on but if you wanted
to play around with this you could go to
the navari demo
project go down to the finance examples
and then there's a
uh zero one B vs code demo.pi and this
is a high file that's riddled with some
um some some bugs and you can use the
built-in debugger with vs code to
actually debug this but before we'll do
that maybe we can try adding an
extension so if you go over to the
little set of squares on the left there
you can try adding an extension that you
might want to use
I've added a few for my myself but let
me see if I find another one down
how much is that worked on editor here
and install and then you'll have this in
your environment for future or when you
when you go work in the future so this
is a nice this is a nice feature as well
um okay I'm gonna navigate back to the
notebook that I started with which is a
zero zero zero one notebook and um we're
going to just briefly highlight as well
that you can SSH from your local machine
into the nepari cluster here are some
instructions on how to do that
it shouldn't uh it should it should be a
very similar process to sshing and
together in the other machine you've
done before the only difference is that
uh to do so on navari or Jupiter Hub in
general you have to go and generate an
API token so you can go to the uh
up control panel here the bottom
and then it'll pop you out here and then
you can go click on token and then
request the new API token
this will be what you need if you're
trying to SSA
so
at this point I think we'll give folks
maybe several minutes just play around
there's some example notebooks at the
bottom or some Pi files and if you'd
like to try sshing in from your local
machine there like I said the
instructions are just just right here
and will be available for questions and
help if you if you have any if you have
any need for it so maybe we'll we'll
read them being at let's say 11 11 20 22
so I'll give you guys seven minutes to
play around but we'll be here for for a
while to help
my turn might try playing around with
one of these myself
economic so we have a one notebook
that's uh pulling data from the Federal
Reserve economic data and data set um
using a NASDAQ datalink API
you have some exercises these the
answers are you know hidden in these
three dots that try uh see if you can uh
you know uh answer the question without
looking at the answers I'd be like
I'm gonna play around I'm gonna play
around with this vs code uh stuff for a
while
um at the bottom you can always change
your your kernel and we'll get into how
we manage environments at a later time
but if you wanted to change your
environment you could do so here
um I'm going to run the debugger to see
what it's like
yeah yeah I do okay
let's see an error
yeah okay I was trying to give ways to
make it
fucktastic
more than one in here
yeah yeah you can't you won't be able to
break anything you can pretty much do
what you would normally do and actually
be fine
oh sorry uh if you go to the zero one
notebook interfaces towards the bottom
there are some instructions um
they are
SSH or SFS fftp from your local machine
at the the repo to check out if you go
if you open your terminal
and there's a link at the on the side
there uh there should be at the very top
a uh GitHub URL that says demo nabari
this is what it should look like
okay
yeah
there's a lot of uh
yeah when you're in Jupiter Hub or
playing around in vs code there's not
much you can do to actually break things
um you know so play around as much as
you like and like I said we'll have the
platform up all weekend so if you'd like
to experiment or play around with some
more feel free too
yeah
okay we might have one minute left how
are people feeling about their progress
on some of the exercises
okay okay
um I'm gonna hand it over to Peyton now
and uh you can keep uh hacking around
for a little longer but Peyton will be
introducing uh how to manage
environments how to scale your Python
and how to share dashboards um so
hi everyone I'm Peyton
um I'm also a software engineer at
on-site
um yeah so the first thing that I'll be
talking to you about can I close this up
okay yeah uh terminal one right terminal
one
um oh you've reverse scrolling
course
okay
uh right so I'm I'm gonna talk to you
about uh one of the core features uh one
of the things that I consider a core
feature
nibari
um
right so so uh this core feature is
called conda store so most people are
used to installing software
but once you start working on data
platforms usually you have less
flexibility installing the software that
you want
because usually it determines what
software you can install
and often if you want to install
something new there's like a request
process for that
and that can take a long
so
on top of that
a lot of Jupiter Hub distributions that
maybe you've used before bake in the
software environment into the docker
image
and so changing the environment means
like a huge infrastructure effort uh one
to like vet the package with
with t and then rebuild the docker image
and redeploy to
um so condo store here is a tool that
makes it
easy to install software
and it gives you control over the
software that you installed while still
being being able to meet the constraints
that are
so what do I mean by that well uh let's
let's just take a look at
uh the existing contest or UI and it
will be uh more apparent what I'm
talking about and also the name will
become clearer
Honda store is actually a tool
s of Honda if you're
here so um
so there's some instructions right here
for uh for managing software
environments
so uh
so if you go to the the file menu
um
whoops
go to the file
and
there's going to be a hub control panel
down at the bottom I I think of this as
like the the home
uh for nabari or nabari home screen
there's a bunch of uh links on the top
uh that we won't talk about just yet but
there is one for environment management
and this is how we're currently managing
uh environments in
uh in the Bari
um and if you click on this link uh
you'll see that there's nothing
populated
now
but in the top right there's a you're
not using such a like zoomed in view
there's going to be a link to login
and so if you click on that link to log
in
you can use your username and password
that you used before
or a listing of
the universe here I'm just going to use
here
once you do that you should see a
listing of all the environment software
environments that you're
that you have access to
um
so let me let me explain a little bit
more about what you're seeing right
so on uh the right maybe I better not
step away but on the right you can see
the environment name it's shown in like
a teal background so there's a geo-n a
demo x-ray environment
and a nabari demo environment
so these are uh you can think of them
like conda environments again if you're
familiar with
that just to the left of that are what
we call namespaces so namespaces are
groupings of environments that are
associated with your user permission
so as a user you can create new
environments and share groups of
environments with other users
administrators can
Grant access or restrict access
to groups of environments or namespaces
so that's what you're seeing here
um and there's there's a little bit more
information uh how big the environment
is shown just nearby
um I'll talk about these these other
links as well but
for now uh you can create a new
environment with this plus button up
here so click on that
and what you'll see is this uh this user
interface that we have right here it's a
it's a code editor so the environments
that are actually getting fed into conda
store are yaml specifications
and so right here I won't ask you to do
this but there is basically a a yaml
specification that looks a lot like
uh conda yaml
and so you would enter uh the name of
your environment and
we're working on a UI which is not ready
for a demo I'll show
some images of later shows a video of it
which removes the necessity of using a
and of course you can also choose the
namespace that you're
so going back to um
list of environments if you click on an
existing environment uh oh actually one
thing I should mention so the global
namespace is accessible to everybody so
I think everybody should be able to see
uh those three namespaces uh or sorry
those three environments in the global
namespace
there's probably also an environment
with your username next to it and only
you have access to that
but of course you can manage who has
access
so so let's take a look at the nibari
demo
garments and in here you'll see an
example of what that yaml
it looks like it's a listing of some
python packages and some other software
and if I scroll down a little bit more
there's a button to edit the environment
and if I if I click on that I can add
new packages to this environment and
submit the new specification to the
condo store
server which will build the environment
and one of the really really cool things
about conda store is that when I make a
change to an environment it will always
save an old version of an environment
it's like it's like Version Control but
for our environment
and so if I add a dependency that's not
quite right or somehow the uh
that it can't be added to the
environment because maybe I mistyped it
or or the environment can't solved you
can always go back to an old version and
it's it's really simple to do all of
these are still environments that are
accessible to me so right now we're
using build 21 I guess we've created 21
different Builds on this navari instance
but I can always go back just by
clicking this check mark next to build
18. and so now if I try to execute uh
a notebook with this nabari demo
environment it will be using build uh
build 18 of this environment instead of
the most recent one so I'm going to go
back to uh build 21
I think this is like one of the most
powerful uh
I guess features of
because it introduces a lot of
pre-producibility to
creating and managing environment
um if I click on a particular build you
can see a bunch of blog information
about when it was built whether it's
successfully completed and so on
and also a listing of what
of what and here we actually have
explicitly called out
the environment
oh you don't have that one um
I'm not sure
yeah yeah so feel free if you'd like to
um if you don't enter the right yaml it
will fail but that's okay I think it
should just tell you
yeah yeah feel free to copy it
some some yaml for him different
environment
okay so this is our old
uh old user interface it's very
functional and it gives a good idea of
what's Happening
oh one other thing these links I I
mentioned uh before
one of condo stores explicit goals is to
serve conda environments in as many
different ways as possible
and so you can take these links and
share like a yaml spec a Docker image an
archive or a log file
with whoever you want so uh so I think
this is a good way of giving other users
we are planning on adding more ways of
serving environments
in the future
okay like I was saying so this is this
is kind of an older interface we are
building a new
extension
um to Jupiter lab to allow users to edit
ing Arts so that's in this new user
interface
thing
and you can see a video of this
command find us
okay all right
all right cool
so let me let me just show off what this
uh what
okay so this is this is what we're
looking towards it goes a little fast so
I'm gonna
uh so like I said this is going to be a
Jupiter lab extension it is a Jupiter
lab extension still in development not
quite ready for uh demoing on the left
hand side here
there are a listing of the different
name spaces that the user has access to
so this user has like a default
namespace
file system namespace a finance and a
product namespaces and you can see some
of those are shared with other
and if you click on one of those
namespaces it shows a list of the
environments there
so this person has a couple of
environments in each of their namespace
and if you click on this little plus
button there's a way to create a new
environment
and you can add an environment name and
a description and then further down a
way to search
patches and
add new packages
into particular versions so this person
is adding
another version or other and then
finally there's
there's a way to enter
which repository that you'd like
and of course the yaml editor is always
there that's really what's happening
under the hood some
yaml spec that's being
created from
from this could wait
and here they are just adding
adding pandas and when they click create
it submits this yaml config to the
condescore server and
the environment is created
and at that moment
once it's finished
it'll show the the status as completed
and that environment will be served as
something that you can select in
Jupiter lab notebook so I I think this
is um a really cool thing because they
didn't need to rebuild the docker image
add in dependencies it basically cuts a
lot of the work of
creating new environments out
from current workflows
right and the user can also uh
edit existing environments or add new
packages and so on and so on
yeah so they're going to add X array
then they'll wind up submitting this new
modified environment
and just as before
the previous build of the environment
will be will be saved
in this little drop down it's
yeah just a previous build that you can
always revert back to
so again this is something that's that's
coming very soon wasn't quite ready for
for example
yeah and then finally you still have
links to
log files archives and yaml files and
Docker images
and I think also we're going to add
Okay cool so that's the uh the new UI
that's coming down the down the line
um
yeah
so going back to the notebook
I'm gonna make this a little bit bigger
again
maybe the command plus
anyway
um
right so I talked about these
environments
[Music]
these environments uh up in the top
right so usually that's how you select a
different different kernels when you
create a new environment with Honda
store uh
environment will appear
Ed the one we're using for all of this
demo by the way the one that has all the
package
books is the global devari demo
and it says Global Dash Global navari
demo because the first Global is
actually the name
cool
yeah so uh so if you'd like you can swap
over to the uh
the X-ray uh
uh environment and you'll be able to
execute this
which requires x-ray but doesn't exist
in
environment
Okay cool so that's that's kind of store
next we're going to be talking about Das
so probably a lot of people are familiar
with desk there were talks about it I
think a lot of people mentioned this but
dask is a library which allows you to
parallelize Computing tasks really
easily
and it lets you scale up from your
laptop
up to a huge cluster on the cloud
so if you're using a cloud computing
service
to run computations with desk
you'll need to use something called task
Gateway which is a server that does
cluster management for
you when you submit a job to it
so
the reason I'm talking about dasc has a
lot of really cool notebook Integrations
that we've included in nabari there's
actually a little task icon which some
of you have probably played with before
but let's just dump jump into an example
we're going to load a data set and run
some computations on it and in the
process you'll get to see some cool
dashboarding that
that here's a gif showing what it can
look like with some of the dashboard
it's it's really cool for showing
progress
you've submitted so if you scroll down
to the bottom there's a little more
information about Das Gateway and so on
and so on
but there's also a link
so click on that
okay so uh so in this first section uh
we're going to take a look at some uh
Indian stock market data so feel free to
execute down to uh to this first line
break right here uh where it starts uh
starts this next scale to large data set
with task
um right so this this Indian stock
market data we can execute this uh this
first
um
oh did I did I do that
we're on build 24.
ah someone must have built a new conda
environment
all right so I'm gonna switch the global
environment back to
one okay cool no for later on
that's all right that's all right that's
all good
oh cool that's not good that's all good
hey condescore lets us get back to it so
nothing's broken uh and I probably need
to restart the kernel yeah okay
okay I'm gonna restart the girl okay so
so the first cell is basically just
getting the location on GC where the
stock market data is stored and if we if
we actually take a look at it
um
it's it's like 70 gigabytes which you'll
notice is way way too big for our uh
instance to load so uh one of the cool
things about dasc is that it provides
um drop-in replacements for a bunch of
tools that you're already used to numpy
pandas in this case which is what we're
we're going to take advantage
advantage and the syntax is like almost
the same as running pandas
yeah we can just execute some of it so
we're going to load Das dot data frame
instead of
pandas data frame
one other difference that you'll notice
with desk is that data is lazily loaded
so it's some huge data set we don't want
to load it into memory but we can still
examine
just a few rows of
it has no problem loading
just five roads out of this
okay cool but the next cell if we were
to uncomment this and actually run it it
would try to compute the max of some
column
this massive data set and we can't do
that like this like I said we only have
eight
days so if you do that it's not bad or
anything but it will just crash the
kernel so so I won't I won't demonstrate
that here so let's uh let's actually
scale this up to a
um so feel free to work through the the
next section I'm going to get some stuff
running because it takes just a minute
to
to start all the workers
what I can say is there's a couple of
warnings in this section on the options
about
the size of the workers and the small
workers are
asked her to launch them
okay uh yeah uh and what I should
mention is there's a dasc kernel up here
as well which uh
has the right package
okay so
um I'm going to import the Das Gateway
set the cluster
one of the really cool things about dasc
is it has tight notebook integration so
when you run this option cell there's
going to be a an option to set a
environment as long as your environment
always matches the environment of the
notebook you're trying to execute then
your workers will be happy and your task
tasks will compete compute uh
successfully and like I said the small
workers actually
core start up faster than the larger one
so I'm just going to choose some
small ones right now and I'm going to
execute a few other notebook cells as
well
so going back to the topic
uh this first cell is establishing a
connection to the task
and you can see that there's actually a
link to the Das Gateway right here
and once you do that then you can start
setting options
on the dash Gateway
related to configuring your work
and that's that's what this next uh
again these these nice IPI widgets that
helpers set up
allow you to configure this stuff one
other thing
the cluster profiles that I mentioned
these are all something that you can
configure using the navari config.dml
which is like the single config file
that you need to
that's something that Esco
so this has some compute profile
I'm not sure what it is but
again it's it's something that you can
and same with the environments available
right so the next thing to do is to
actually create a new cluster with the
options uh that you you selected and
once you do that uh there's some
information pops up about
how you want the cluster to scale so you
can enforce manual scaling say I want my
cluster to have 10 workers or something
like here we're going to use adaptive
scaling
and you can either use this this widget
to configure that or you can do that
programmatically
we have entered into this notebook
so we've told this cluster we want to
run between 1 and 10. workers and
Das scheduler will scale up as necessary
and then finally once you have a cluster
started you can get the client which if
you're familiar with desk
um
you will have seen before now before we
go further on when you display this
client in the notebook there's a handy
link to a dashboard
uh so
if you would click on that link
uh there should be a login screen that
you come to or it you might come to a
login screen which will ask for
and if you if you enter your credentials
it'll take you to this really cool
dashboard which shows a lot of
information about
how the cluster is doing what it's doing
what tasks and system resources it's
consuming
so that's really useful but
uh you can also take advantage of the
notebook integration
the task offers by clicking on this uh
this little button on the left hand
has a little cut off but I I think you
can see where I'm where I'm
okay
uh and initially it'll say the
dashboard's not connected but if you
just copy paste this
by this dashboard link
into here
and then click the little magnifying
glass if your cluster is up and running
you'll get a selection of different
widgets that you can use during your
computation so I like to use the the
cluster map so I just click on that and
it opens up this uh Tandy little
extra tab
and I'll also get the the task
nothing's also cool
so I'm going to put that there
cool and then in the interest of not
crowding everything I'll close that off
okay so then
uh now we have our dashboard set up
we've established a connection to das
Gateway and started our cluster uh we're
now ready to run some processing on
and if you if you want you can uncomment
the next cell and actually run this it
takes a minute or two to run because
it's 70 gigabytes of data and so yeah
that takes a little while so feel free
to do that if you'd like I'm going to
show you just a shorter demo in the
interest of time using task array which
is the drop-in replacement for uh
numpy's ND arrays
and
if you've seen this before or if you've
used numpy before it all looks pretty
familiar like all of this is a numpy
compatible syntax up until you get to
the point where it says compute and you
can think of the previous uh
uh notebook cells as like setting up the
computation
and then the compute as saying okay go
ahead and do this because again dask is
a
lazy execution by
and when I run compute
um I will submit the the task to the
cluster and
you can see that it's it's doing
something right now so it's
it's one a node in this cluster Mouse
represents like the
the main node and this is a worker and
so it's transmitting some some data to
to the worker and that's some task
stream
and if you have adaptive scaling enabled
um dask will recognize that you have a
really big task for it to compute and it
will automatically add other workers as
necessary
so now we have four going there's lots
of data being transferred
yeah and so this this will run for just
a moment and eventually it'll decide
that we haven't gone fast enough and
it'll add a ton of workers and then
right as we do that it'll end so that's
pretty cool I love these uh
visualizations they're they're really
interesting and useful
useful and at the end we've computed uh
the mean of some random
yeah
okay so the last thing to do before we
end
is always close down your your cluster
because uh these are things that are
running in the notebook
they're actually running on some
computer
yeah they cost real money
cool
okay so the next thing I'd like to get
to
is uh uh dashboards
so
um
so many of you have probably heard of
some of the really cool dashboarding uh
tools that exist in the python ecosystem
uh that allow you to build like
interactive data visualizations and turn
them into web apps
so some of these are like uh
okay
partly Dash stream lit there's a bunch
of others as well
and
we in nabari nabari you have the
capability
creating and hosting uh dashboards like
these
and
it's all built on top of
a key book which
is permissioning system
and so it makes it really easy to share
dashboards
with other users
whoever you want
so let's walk through making a dashboard
so if you scroll down here there's a
section that says how does it work
uh and it's it's pretty straightforward
if you're familiar with one of these
Frameworks uh the idea is that you
create a a python file or a notebook
built using one of these Frameworks and
there's a nice interface in nibari to
act so
we can we can demo this live so
um
inside the the home directory
uh there's a shared
a shared folder and inside there there's
an example Direct
direct and inside the examples directory
there's a couple of uh notebooks and
python files which are built using these
uh Frameworks they're they're just
really simple uh visualizations not
going to ask you to write these although
you can if you would like what I would
suggest doing is going to going to this
directory and right clicking
foreign
oh it's two figures no
there it goes
all right and then uh and then copy the
path
because this is what you'll need later
on to actually
and then
we go back to the hub control panel
which is our navari home so click on
that
and up at the top you'll see next to the
environment management uh
so click on that there
and here you should see this new
dashboard
there's also going to be down below this
dashboards from others I'm on escal's
account so
it's showing a different dashboard that
I've already deployed I think you should
be able to see that extra dashboard as
well but I'll show that to you in a
minute
so click on the the new dashboard link
and give it a name
um task Dash
one
yeah
and you can give it a description
and like I said there's a the
possibility of restricting access to
certain users or branding access to all
users so that's something that you can
configure here just by clicking on these
buttons for now I'm going to let
everyone see this dashboard
and finally um you can choose whether to
Source a dashboard from a git repository
or in this case we're serving a file
from the Jupiter
nursery and then down at the bottom it
to you for the
to the dashboard
thing so just paste in what you've
copied
and then select the framework that
you've chosen so I chose this Dash
streamlit example so I'm going to choose
the Streamlight framework and finally
there's some content environments here
I'm going to use the the global navari
demo
environment
then if you click save It'll ask you
what kind of instance do you want to
serve this on
um
suggest a small instance
but it's up to you
you probably don't need the compute
resources
of everything
and it will it will start and it takes
another minute I know some of you uh
took like a few seconds to get your
Jupiter lab instance
right it's the same story here it's
starting
while that's loading uh I can show you
look at that everybody's already done
all these so
I can show you the New York City Taxi
Cab data uh which surely you haven't
seen before
um yeah so this is what it looks like
when you when you build one of these
dashboards I think this is super cool
you can you can share this kind of
information with
with your your co-workers and I just
think it's a a great way of displaying
data data there's a little um
binary thingy right here that lets you
choose different pickup times and it
updates
cool
so I think that's it for uh for
dashboard
um yeah feel free to check out the other
uh the other dashboards that
are creating
there's definitely more information
about this we're using something called
CDs dashboards to actually
accomplish all of this there's some
other examples in there so feel free to
check those out
for now I
we should probably fall into the south
side
let's go
all right
um how's one how's everyone doing so far
good okay well um so far we've demoed a
handful of features and services that
have that are integrated by default into
nabari um but you might be wondering how
do we actually deploy navari instance
and
this is what we're going to talk about
now if you were here at the beginning I
I did kick start a deployment off uh
using a single command and we're gonna
revisit that and see if it's actually
deployed successfully it should have
taken about 30 minutes to 45 minutes so
hopefully it's done by now
um
we wanted to just highlight the some of
the key a few takeaways from from this
particular notebook which are that you
can initialize your navari configuration
uh so in the park config.yaml with the
single with a single CLI command
and that single uh that single uh config
file controls all the
um
controls everything about your nabari
cluster so you don't need to make any
changes anywhere else this is the one
place where you would make those changes
and then redeploy and then the second
thing being that uh the deploy command
itself is very simple under the hood is
all managed by terraform so we're
passing the inputs from the config file
over to a yam over to uh terraform
script and the terraform is the one
actually deploying
so
there's a lot of information here about
what what it's like to get started but I
just wanted to highlight that one of the
reasons why we think nepari is a useful
platform is that we spent a lot of time
integrating all these services and
making it as easy as possible to deploy
so
um you know all these things are are
possible you can do all these you can
integrate all these Services into your
own Jupiter Hub into your own Jupiter
Hub but we've we've done all that work
for you and now you can kind of just get
started right away and not have to worry
about the administration and
I.T components of managing a Jupiter Hub
so
um
if we want to follow along or have a
have a look at this Eli will do so
quickly but I just want to highlight
this one
uh
one image I guess which kind of outlines
what CLI kind of tries to do so there's
a Nick command and there's a deploy
command and there's a distort command
the the init is what I like I said
before it generates the config file and
the deploy is what actually is used to
deploy the cluster when you're done with
your deployment you can always run
napari destroy and it'll do the job of
destroying and removing all the the
cloud resources that were created in the
Second Step
um so but for now if we want to move
over to a terminal so we have a terminal
open like I have here
uh you should be you should be in the
global navari demo environment that
should have been started for you
automatically but if not then you can
just run conda
Mario demo already there so that should
be fine you run to Bari
um this is a relatively new CLI that
we've just added
um so um we're still kind of uh
experimenting with it but I think it
looks quite neat and there are a handful
of commands and some help messages that
might be helpful for people getting
started the big three that I like to
call out like I said earlier are the
init deploy and Destroy so let's have a
look at the init
in it
so if you look at the help command
you'll see that there are quite a few
options that you can cast to your init
command these are actually trying to
we're trying to get some information
from the user and then add those add
those options to the configuration file
um but uh as you can see adding all of
these
adding all of these options to a
to a CLI command can be quite cumbersome
so we've added a a guided in it so
that's what I recommend people getting
started with so if everyone could do
navaria knit dash dash guided Dash init
like this
it'll uh walk you through a quick
questionnaire that'll help generate this
config file for you so we'll hit enter
uh there's some there are some links and
helpful information about what this
config file does and where you can get
more information
is our home page have a have a look at
it when you get a chance
and then there are some other some other
messages here so the first question is
going to ask is where do you want you to
where do you want to deploy your Nepali
cluster so at the moment we have a few
options uh local is how you would deploy
it if you wanted to deploy it on a local
machine so your your actual computer or
laptop currently this is only available
for Linux OS but we're working on adding
support for obviously Mac and
and windows existing is how you would
deploy a
navari cluster on an existing cloud
provider so we have four options listed
below but if you are trying to deploy on
a clustered um from a different provider
you could do so I know I have personally
deployed nabari on on Oracle Cloud so
that's another another option but for
now you can just select any of the four
uh Cloud providers you'd like so I'm
going to do let's say I'm going to do
digital I'll do digital ocean I'll type
in a you don't need to type in an actual
token in your spine just type in
something
so it register registers some keystrokes
um and once you get past that section
It'll ask you
about what kind of project name you'd
like to give your project so in this
instance our project name is uh demo
demo Dash nabari but you could obviously
want to pick a name that's
um appropriate for you and your
organization so maybe do something like
high data NYC
as my project name
next we're going to give a give a URL or
sorry a domain name to
um to the config this is where we would
actually be deploying our cluster to so
make sure you own that domain name but
um you can type in something like
my data nyc.nabari
Dot
Dev
the next question is going to ask you
about
um
the
identity provider you'd like to choose
so at the moment we have a few options
GitHub off Sierra or custom so customers
you can pretty much add any other
identity provider if it's not listed
here or you can just do the very most
simple option which is password so you
just everyone has a username and
password and that's how they log in but
we'll just do that for now
um get Ops is a a way of managing the
deployment in the future so the first
time you deploy you'll probably do so on
your local machine but thereafter you
might want to pass this job off to a
cicd pipeline and this is how you would
do so I'll just give an example of what
kind of questions you might be asked so
at the moment you can deploy
um
your
body cluster from
GitHub or gitlab I'm just GitHub for now
you would add a orgs I'll just add my
um my my username on GitHub and give it
a give it a name so I
NYC
and then ultimately if you have your
GitHub token exported it'll actually
create this repo for you on the fly but
I won't do so right now
um another option that is recommended is
adding an SSL cert and if you add an
email address in the next for the next
question we will automatically generate
a let's encrypt uh cert that'll be
applied to the whole platform so you
don't have to worry about that and it
automatically renews in the background
so there's none of that SSL server
managing that needs to be done
yes oh shoot I didn't have an email
address
anyways um
the next question will be the next
questions are more of the advanced
configuration items and you can have a
look at what those are but for them for
the most part they're not all that
important for for basic deployments
um but you have a look you can say oh
where do you want this terraform state
to be provisioned locally remote remote
is a default
um
what namespace you want your kubernetes
cluster to be deployed under
um Dev is the default
um and if you if you have a version
you'd like to to to
um to use and you can select uh um a
specific version of kubernetes but we
won't do that either so
anyways once you hit enter you'll you'll
see a whole bunch of text at the bottom
and uh you'll see that you we have
generated
a navari
a config so if you just cap that out
you'll see there are
a big yaml spec that talks about what
defines what your um the byte cluster
will look like so I'm actually going to
open this in
so yeah anyways so we'll go to the top
and kind of walk through some of these
sections
um the project name we talked about
before earlier the provider so the do
stands for digital digital ocean
um and then the domain name under which
you'll be you'll be deploying
certificate that we just talked about as
well
um security and authentication we
selected password as the most basic
option but like I said you could add
GitHub authentication auth zero which is
what we have as an organization here at
quantite
um Piccolo group password this is how
you would first log into your uh P1
admin console to add and remove
uh managed groups and permissions and
whatnot
we have here the list of default images
for for the Jupiter Hub and Jupiter lab
and nasworker these often are not
changed or touched but if you need to
you could do so
um
and there's a whole bunch of other
changes you can make you can update the
theme
um that you see when you first log in
the theme that you're seeing is the
default theme but you could always
customize that to your organization or
or the team you're working on
you can enable and disable a whole bunch
of features we talked about uh the CDs
dashboards that you could do that here
do that there as well
and uh towards the bottom you'll see
some more
um cloud-specific
um
configuration items so these are the
node groups that are being deployed with
the cluster so we have three node groups
General user and worker so workers where
the desk workers spin up on user is
where the users log in and that's how
they get those these are the default
default um
instance types for those for those users
and this all this can be configured you
can change the Max and Min you can
combine these two together add other GPU
instances and so on so this is where
those changes would be made
um and then you can Define from those
instances what kind of profiles are
available to the user so small is
splitting up the big instance or the the
user instance into two different
profiles and the medium is putting all
the resources in in one one
a one node
and at the bottom we've listed we've
also just included two default
environments that build automatically so
that people can get started using Das
and dashboards without having to fiddle
with the managing environments right
away so
that's the nabaric big um any questions
about the the config file I know there's
a lot of different sections but once you
get used to you know um like adding and
deploying it it should be fairly
straightforward
okay um I think I might move over to
um having a look
oh sorry
right
yeah so if you wanted if you wanted to
have it be uh if you want the repo to be
created for you automatically then
you'll need to export those
those credentials if you just you just
want it to be
um
if you just want to list what repo
you're actually going to be deploying to
you don't actually need to have your
your
let me see if I can show you real quick
so if I go to
this section right here this is uh we're
asking that question because we're we're
going to be pushing this repo up to a
um every so I pushing this big pile up
to a repo and then uh once we render a
handful of uh workflow files then uh
this will kick start any deployment in
the future so if you make a modification
to the embroidery config you open a pull
request and that photo pull request gets
merged back into main or whatever other
Branch you want to specify uh then that
will kick start the deployment for you
so that was a way of making it easy for
people and teams to to manage their
deployment without having to do so on
your actual local machine
yeah okay
okay yeah that's right
yeah
maybe I think I have my my my browser
open I can just maybe navigate you uh
and show what it looks like real quick
on this topic
so this uh to the the deployment that
we're actually working on right now this
is what it looks like in GitHub for
example so um last night I I opened a
pull request to increase some resources
on the platform
um there's a and once this got merged
back into Maine you'll see that it
actually kicked off a redeployment
we kicked off a redeployment so
yeah so this is uh so this is actually
running the deployment
um took 13 minutes for the head to do a
handful of bigger changes but usually
it's pretty quick
um and this is a the entire entire
deployment script happening all within
uh all within uh GitHub actions which is
really convenient to not have to do it
on your laptop
um
let me go back to where I was okay so we
talked about the init we talked about
the deployment so now let's see if the
deployment I could come at the beginning
of the of the talk is actually okay very
good it actually did work so
um I'm going to navigate to
um the pi data
me.nabari.dev and
show you that this was just deployed
while we were talking so in the
background I had the config file which
we generated and we now deployed it and
it took like I said 30 minutes to an
hour depending on the internet
connection and some other things but now
you have the entire plot you have the
entire cluster up and up and running and
now you can add users make changes uh to
your theme and whatnot and go from there
so that's
um one of the main motivations I think
for using a platform like uh nabari is
that it's really easy and simple to
manage and the deployment process is
quite quite simple relative to to some
of the other other platforms so
um that is it for the setup and the
deployment steps but any other questions
on that on the front
they're very similar yeah the the
current demo that you see is basically
the exact or is pretty much the vanilla
navari deployment there have been a few
changes to allow for us to include so
many users and we've also made some
changes to
um
we had an environment and we've added
the ability for users to log in without
having to register or yeah with with
only having to register usually that
wouldn't be the case you wouldn't have
you wouldn't allow people to register in
a deployment like we have here but uh we
obviously need to wait for you guys to
all jump in quickly so um there are very
minor changes from what you see and what
an actual vanilla the party deployment
would look like
look like good question
like this
yeah that's a good question
yeah that's a good question so I'll show
you the command that we ran that I ran
to deploy with so normally it would just
be this first Top Line which is navari
demo dot uh Dash C and then the config
file if you're if you have cloudflare as
your provider you could add that there
and then you have this class this DNS
Auto provision that will automatically
do it for you if you don't if at the
moment that we only provide this service
for cloudflare but if you have your own
service part way through the script
it'll stop and it'll ask you to map your
your A and B or cname or your a record
to an actual IP address on whatever
domain provider you have so
um that would be a manual process during
the deployment but if you're using
cloudflare you can do it automatically
but that step is is only a one step um
one Interruption during the entire
deployment so
but that's a good question
um and we're gonna wrap up by going over
to the last notebook which is the
inclusion notebook
um
I think we've we've covered a lot in a
short amount of time but I hope we
um made it clear what nabari is uh and
what some of the features and core
services are uh Honda store for managing
environments CBS dashboards for sharing
um sharing dashboards um to ask for
scaling up your compute fairly quickly
and um and then lastly we also talked
about how easy it is to get started with
generating and generating an initial
file and then deploying it on the cloud
provider of your choice
um we have some so we have some brochure
um
um or some some brochures that we've
added into the to The Notebook you can
kind of look at it more but
um
this is the point where we kind of open
it up for questions there are some
additional features you can you can
check out here as well we've integrated
Argo workflows K batch you know
dashboard or sorry monitoring dashboards
not quite CBS dashboards a way that this
is a different way to just check in on
how your cluster is doing and then
obviously there's the Jitsu video chat
on the on the right here
um anyways but um thank you very much uh
I'd like to you know thank you all for
coming and also thank a whole bunch of
people who worked on this uh Chris and
Tanya Benny uh Avita Amit and our
hospital this is the main core
development team at the moment we have
Adam obviously has contributed a lot on
the one of our other co-workers this
contributed a lot contributed a lot as
well and um lastly we've we've
integrated a whole bunch of uh core data
Pi data platforms and services into the
platform so what this wouldn't be
possible it wouldn't be possible if we
didn't have the the support and packages
such as Jupiter Das CDs dashboards and a
whole bunch of others so I'd like to
give them a huge thanks as well but um
that's about it for our um our tutorial
now we're going to open it up to your
question but uh thank you very much
[Applause]